et la nourriture dans un hélicoptère
censé piloter un hélico
la cia a été infiltrée je n'ai confiance
en personne en dehors de vous trois vont
tous vous tuer non je les en empêcherait
les comment tu les en empêchera j'y
réfléchis il réfléchit
j'vais ou bng pour la gauche
qu'est ce que tu attends je sente du
haut d'un mur
mission impossible fallout dieu mais
chut
youtube charts
mission impossible for world
on est au chaud
ouais
mission impossible forlan au cinéma le
1er août
mission impossible fallout
il ne peut y avoir de paix sont d'abord
une grande souffrance que la souffrance
est grande plus la plus grande la fin
que vous avez toujours redouté et or et
c'est vous qui allez morts sur la
conscience
j'ai prié pour que ce ne soit pas vrai
salomone ligne s'est évadé à paris
et maintenant le monde est en danger
c'est la mission de la cia nous utiliser
un scalpel
je préfère un marteau
c'est pas une bonne idée c'est parce
qu'on dit à chaque fois honnêtement
il n'est pas là que pour observer c'est
un tueur
je n'ai confiance quand vous croire
si vous dérapez il est autorisé à vous
tuer ce sont les ordres
sans rancune
tu es obligé bon à gauche
ça les papilles mais qu'est ce que tu
attends je sente du haut d'un immeuble
au pardon bonne chance
quand le vent va tourner et tout perdre
à tous ceux qu'il a aimés
tu ne sais pas dans quoi tu t'es engagé
tu ferais mieux de temps d'aller
s'il te plaît contre toi
ça ne nous ressemble pas éteint
peut-être qu'il est temps que ça change
[Musique]
accepté l'héritage ce qui est fait c'est
terminé
c'est terminé quand nous décidons que
c'est terminé c'est parti
[Musique]
mission impossible forbach ou cinéma le
1er août